[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission sur le sport
local qui va vous réchauffer par cette
température glaciale il y aura il y aura
comme d'habitude des analyses des débats
et des duels qui nous vous laisserons a
pas de glace entre les incroyables
chroniqueurs aujourd'hui ils sont cinq
autour de la table et ils n'ont pas
froid aux yeux présentation en musique
on commence à ma droite c'est peut-être
un des chroniqueurs les plus givré sur
ce plateau
les adeptes de sports extrêmes il est
vice champion du monde de cyclisme sur
piste master's champion d'europe
n'hésitent pas à rouler à plus de 70 km
heure dans les virages à 43 degrés sur
la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
yade jarrier est avec nous une heure
quand soit michael au jour yann alors
vous êtes réchauffer en loge un
réchauffement en début de cette émission
a pas eu le temps de se réchauffer même
le
le peu de temps que j'ai passé entre la
voiture et les studios ont suffi à me
classer les doigts voilà du coup vous
êtes givré vraiment j'ai froid au givre
est certain de 10 sur faut il faut pas
avoir peur quand on jette à plus de 70 à
l'heure sous derrière une moto parfois
et d'un on dépasse bien largement les 70
on passe à gauche
musique c'est notre reine des neiges à
nous avec ses pouvoirs à la rive à
réaliser des figures exceptionnelles en
pole dance discipline qui mêle danse
acrobatie échange une barre à nous vient
tout droit de versailles notre
ambassadrice de charme la ravissante
helen de la grange nous fait l'honneur
de venir sur cette émission
bonjour hélène bonjour fraîche mais
franchement fraîchement alors vous vous
êtes plutôt fan de la neige de la glace
de la neige
ouais ouais pas trop moi les cocotiers
ça ne va pas mieux
on peut faire des concessions et 7,6
plongée cocotiers dans sa maman mais ce
cas les missions comme ça y'a du jard y
est on repasse de l'autre côté à musique
c'est un véritable dur à cuire une tête
brûlée le gel le givre le verglas et
même les icebergs lui font pas peur
le gladiateur c'est son surnom dans
cette émission pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
salut tél
bonjour caire alors vous la neige à moi
sa faveur
moi ça farte j'adore quand ça quand ça
va vite sur des planches ski plutôt
opaque surf mais ce qui fait que j'ai
adoré j'adorais l'âge ou la région et
les yvelines sous la neige
top parfait on repasse à la gauche
musique la neige ne lui fait pas peur
les glaçons il les prend plutôt vos
pendant l'apéritif avec une modération
bien sûr comme toujours c'est également
un as du patinage artistique la
réalisent des figures qui en ont un
surpris ou devrais je dire à figer à
plus d'un sur place coach genlis est
avec nous pendant une heure sur cette
émission où les courants vikash de
plaisir et ex vauchamps eagle vous sera
tout ce dont j'ai besoin des câbles à
l'apéritif on est d'accord ce avec des
gars sur les tifos blavec
ils ont fait boule de neige avec moi
mais j'ai arrêté parce qu'il voulait me
la carotte
non ça commencerait par cette émission
au termine à la droite musique c'est le
petit génie de cette émission le cerveau
de ce talk il revient tout droit d'une
expédition en antarctique sur la
banquise où il est particulier l'esprit
l'équipe des pingouins ses études lui
permettront d'appliquer leurs techniques
de cohésion chez les templiers
d'elancourt le professeur frederik
andersen le directeur sportif des
templiers d'elancourt est avec nous
parce si on parlait ce pas
bonsoir tout le monde bonjour frédéric
alors cette expédition très bien ramé
des techniques pour les templiers à
construire des igloos avec la neige sur
le terrain tout ça on va passer
maintenant au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
football verset s'est incliné de
justesse en 32e de finale de coupe
gambardella nous évoquerons également le
premier tournoi de heath portes du sport
électronique qui s'est tenue à
versailles mais avant de développer ces
thèmes coup de projecteur sur le
handball
[Musique]
c'était le match à ne pas manquer pour
les passionnés de handball féminin ici
paris affronter ce samedi 3 février
l'équipe norvégienne des bipeurs
christiansen en coupe d'europe au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le deuxième match organisé
par le club francilien dans la structure
en moins d'un an l'événement attiré plus
de 4000 spectateurs
sur le terrain les vipères ce s'impose
d'un but dans les dernières minutes
contre issy paris score final 25 à 24
l'ambiance du vélodrome n'a pas réussi à
empêcher la défaite pour les joueuses
d'île de france on écoute les réactions
et ses démarches avec des joueuses très
expérimentées 1 une bonne partie des
joueuses de voirie parce son équipe de
norvège dont la gardienne
l'arrière gauche la dhimmitude la demi
centre est
ouais il nous a pas beaucoup réussi
cette année mais bon c'est gagner le
prochain match de coupe d'europe
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore
regarde je le disais 4000 spectateurs
étaient présents au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi eux une
cinquantaine de norvégiens qui avaient
fait le déplacement pour ce choc
européen pour la 5e journée de la phase
de phase de groupe on écoute la réaction
de ceux supporters à la mi temps du
match
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si on va gagner je pense
que c'est un match difficile je suis un
peu effrayé de l'issue de la rencontre
les j'ai l'espoir qu'on puisse le faire
genre ça vous a plu
c'est un petit extrait ah ouais ouais il
savait pas trop où aller faire la fête
mais qui s'est dit très emballé un one
man mais ouais non mes très bons amis
s'écarter système 4 2 comme ça ça a dû
coûter cher à l'alcool avec modération
et modération toujours yann ça fait
plaisir quand même de voir des images de
joie dans ce peloton de 50 un dj chaque
fois ci toujours voir ce vélodrome plein
et je rêverais et je rêve toujours de le
voir plein côté du cyclisme voilà pour
l'heure il ya une suite complète
dimanche
n'hésitez pas à venir si la finale de la
coupe coupe d'hiver grosse agate
personnes et 50 mais les norvégiens
alors finalement du coup l'histoire
s'est plutôt bien terminée pour ce
supporter avec une victoire 25 à 24
qu'on soit ici par ailleurs je le disais
précédemment donc c'était donc le
deuxième rendez vous organisé par ici
paris dans ce groupe de saint quentin en
yvelines en un an cinq mille supporters
pour la première édition contre brest
4000 pour ce match contre les vipères
christiane scène la question sur ce
thème l'équipe d'issy paris doit-elle
s'implanter au vélodrome oui et non près
de dix mille supporters sur deux
rencontres
non non oui non
oui enfin titulaire mais hélène j'ai pas
trop d'avis sur la question
après oui moi tant qu'il ya des
supporters
je pense que déjà à l'aller les
personnes se sentent soutenus etc mais
après je ne saurais pas je ne sais pas
fenech anderson je prends trop basse et
les barbouzes ou non tout de suite à ce
passé par le club du coin quoi c'est
vrai que si on commence à faire venir
juste sur les résultats sportifs
ça peut être difficile de développer
balles et les clubs aux alentours donc
puis c'est cci-ci quoi c'est pas c'est
pas c'est même pas le département donc
c'est bien si ça reste un événement
exceptionnel ça permet de d'attirer un
peu plus les projecteurs sur le
département mais si ça devenait régulier
peut-être qu'on en parle et moi aussi
donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
français - une bonne idée serre
chevalier
le groupe s'appelle déjà ici paris s'il
fallait rajouter en plus 50 ans quelque
part ça tiendrait plus sur les bio par
exemple tous les sports qui font de la
délocalisation profite ponctuellement de
la notoriété en train c'est que ça amène
je pense qu'il faut garder le côté un
petit peu et événementiel est un peu
exceptionnel d'une délocalisation aussi
réussi soit elle dans les hauts de saint
quentin mais pas perdre pas perdre on va
dire la mieux l'âme du club
si c'est ici c'est paris c'est il ya
déjà il ya déjà deux localités non je ne
pense pas une troisième et gardons côté
un petit peu festif et exceptionnelle de
la délocalisation genre vous êtes un
petit peu comme pierre chevallier vous
pensez que le côté exceptionnel de
l'événement finalement attire le monde
plus qu'un match de championnat
classique
il ya bien sûr mais sur tout a été dit
là tout est dit qu'on niveau du rugby
par exemple lorsqu'on fait des affiches
du top 14 au stade de france parce qu'on
sait que cette affiche là va remplir le
stade
voilà on délocalise mais après de là à
en faire vraiment et d'ailleurs je ne
pense pas je ne pense pas que il y
aurait à chaque match quatre mille
personnes entre quatre et cinq mille
personnes à chaque match
de cette équipe donc non restos comme ça
les dépôts actuellement et c'est très
bien comme ça
au niveau économique c'est positif quand
même pour le club il arrive à engranger
une recette de près de 10000 spectateurs
est-ce qu'ils auraient pas tendance à
développer encore plus ces matches-là
yann jarrier bas un sim et donc balle
trouver les bonnes les bonnes salles et
proche de proches de leurs dans leur
département où je pense que voilà il ya
des salles comme coubertin qui doit être
capable de les accueillir ils sont
ponctuellement aussi à pierre de
coubertin 4000 places donc
donc voilà c'est ça demande une
logistique et moi moins importante
ça dérange moins les cyclistes abonnés
qui veulent venir femme de louis jeune
je le place et je le place donc ouais
donc pour moi après voilà en effet c'est
sympa c'est c'est bien de temps en temps
mais voilà je pense qu'une fois par an
c'est largement suffisant pour pour pour
cette équipe
après peut-être d'autres équipes de hand
qui peuvent y prendre prendre l'exemple
là pourquoi pas n'est pas que ce soit
toujours les mêmes qui viennent là ça
poserait ça risque de poser problème est
justement de moins créer l'événement et
donc les filles enfin les chambres ne
viendront pas alors que si on peut avoir
une à mach 2 un match des bleus par
exemple sur sur le vélodrome ça ça peut
être sympa
ou alors une grosse une grosse équipe
masculine aussi qu'ils puissent venir
oui là ça peut être ça peut être sympa
mais voilà une info il en faut pour tout
le monde il faut faire tourner quoi
genlis à la limite
à la limite ça pourrait être intéressant
au niveau du handball mais par rapport
aux spectateurs la jette à lui dire que
les gens étaient un peu trop loin et il
faudrait supprimer il faudrait supprimer
la piste cycliste
autour pour justement pouvoir peut-être
revaloriser cette cette infrastructure
j'ai vu j'ai vu cette interrogation sur
les réseaux sociaux et il y à une
spectatrice qui a mis une photo
justement de ce qu'elle voyait de là où
elle est et elle disait que c'était très
très bien qu'ils avaient assez de recul
et c'était vraiment parfait pour pouvoir
mieux qu'à marché classique je vais pas
dire que c'est n8 yamaska sic je peux
pas jouer c'est parce qu'elle a dit mais
à la dic voilà c'était les emplacements
été parfait mais je pense que en effet
le fait d'être un poil plus loin n'est
pas n'est pas gênant et les gradins du
vélodrome sont quand même très très bien
fait pour pour ça il fallait qu anderson
le duc ou like you ponctuellement dans
ce stade dans ce mélo de saint quentin
en yvelines
il joue d'habitude dans la le palais des
sports robert à charpentier qui fait
1700 places elles sont dans le top 3 ici
paris elles sont dans le top 3 du
championnat de france
est ce que finalement il y aurait pas
tendance à aller vers une salle plus
grande avec plus de spectateurs pour
attirer deux meilleures joueuses des
joueuses qui sont qui jouent dans des
dans des stades et des gymnases de 5000
6000 10000 places
je pense que la ola du lieu des matches
et des entraînements c'est surtout le
niveau sportif qui intéresse les
athlètes donc je pense que ça attirera
plus que se maintiennent à un niveau
élevé qu'elles poursuivent leur
progression au niveau européen pour être
plus attractive
plutôt que de plutôt que de changer de
lieu de deux lieux de rencontre après
non je pense que il ya le vélodrome et à
d'autres il ya d'autres salles aussi
peut-être plus proche qui peut
intéresser c'est plus intéressant d'un
point de vue financier effectivement
d'avoir plus de 1700 places
surtout que rezaï va faire quatre cinq
mille entrées sur les matches à eux de
voir ce qui les arrange aussi ça fait
quand même une petite trotte depuis ici
pour le faire régulièrement à l'anis et
c'est rapide kansas et pas assez
pratique ici ici saint quentin en
yvelines avec la ligne c c
ils peuvent faire des supporters
peut-être localisation cherche pas tous
à vouloir jouer devant beaucoup
spectateurs parce que sinon monaco il y
aurait personne qui jouait là-bas
après il ya d'autres avantages et à
monaco est-ce qui est ce qu'ils peuvent
perdre des des supporters du co à
délocaliser leurs leur match je pense
que les supporters qui ont envie de
suivre les matchs se déplace de toute
façon on parle pas de distance
très éloignées et c'est aussi l'occasion
d'en gagner et puis aussi d'intéresser
de jandin du coin qui pourrait pas
forcément fait le déplacement jusque
dans 92 pour aller voir un match comme
ça voilà apprécie donc puisque
l'approché de la rétine et non
exceptionnel donc du bon ça fait quand
même bouger ça fait quand même
en tout cas les dirigeants d'ici paris
envisage déjà de renouveler l'expérience
de façon ponctuelle dans les prochains
mois au vélodrome 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines après le handball
y'aura peut pas de pistard dans les
prochains mois mgi rien vous avez pas
trop faire la tête si la piste au cutter
après le ballon passe à un autre sport
collectif le football ont joué ce
dimanche 4 février un 32e de finale de
coupe gambardella la coupe de france des
moins de 19 ans dans leur stade de
porchefontaine les versets qui évolue en
r2 ont frôlé l'exploit ils se sont
inclinés 1 à 0 contre guingamp une
équipe nationale en manque de réussite
les versaillais ont touché deux fois les
poteaux et ont multiplié les occasions
ils se sont finalement inclinés sur ce
coup franc détourné en deuxième mi-temps
on écoute les réactions
le réalisme demain on a deux bars si ça
s'arrête pas ils ont eu un coup france
il le met c'est dommage mais c'est le
foot on voit qu'il n'était pas si serein
que ça en deuxième mi temps notamment
surtout à la fin où ça commençait il a
eu du mal à relancer eux également donc
c'est dommage je reste frustré parce que
un poteau une barre une action un peu
litigieuse à la fin on se dit que on se
dit qu'il y avait peut-être la place de
de par ses écrits l'exploit la question
sur ce thème la réussite ce travail tél
oui ou non vous êtes tous d'accord
bon ben ce soir le débat genre oui on
sera réussie de ce travail forcément
seulement on a réussi de ce travail
c'est la base toute l'équipe est à
l'ombre par le sport collectif même un
sport individuel le sport par définition
c'est le travail intensif pour arriver à
une performance la plus élevée possible
donc
c'est évidemment c'est évident après bon
c'est le la magie du sport surtout du
football en plus puisque la avaient ils
ont dominé finalement ils ont touché
deux fois la barre
et puis ils sont pris par de francs un
coup franc qui est dévié et voilà donc
ce n'était pas ce n'était pas leur jour
de chasse sur ce sur ce match là mais
forcément on ne peut pas on peut pas sur
un match on mettra une question le
travail de toute une saison
facteur chance pour vos pierre chauvel
je pense que c'est justement là c'est la
chance qui se provoque la réussite qui
se prépare mais il s'est surtout c'est
l'état d'esprit général et collective
qui fait que sur des grands rendez vous
même à même en moins de 19 ans rambarde
et là on est capable de régler un tout
petit peu plus la mire et et de mettre
le but au fond et c'est cette cet état
d'esprit-là de j'imagine pouvoir
travailler dans les équipes c'est à dire
que provoque un peu la chance par un
travail comme dijon un travail régulier
des entraînements réguliers qui font que
même contraint un plus gros comme le
l'en-avant guingamp ça ça passe ça passe
au lieu de mettre deux bars mais on est
le mien où il ya des provocations et
puis on passe on passe au final c'est ça
qui les a priori qui va se chercher
c'est la chance qui se provoque
il ya du sérieux c'est un blocage
psychologique
ce manque de réalisme parfois alors sur
un match de foot je pense pas parce que
c'est quand même 90 minutes vous allez
avoir plusieurs
plusieurs actions et au fur à mesure que
le temps va passer
la formule est la question mais au fur
et à mesure que le temps a passé
le facteur va se
la question est ce que c'est un blocage
psychologique non c'est pas un blocage
psychologique puisque une fois qu'on met
dans le bain une fois qu'on est rentré
la pression la pression sur la pression
s'enlève voilà c'est ça que je voulais
dire maintenant et sur l'école de
divisions qui séparaient les moments où
le gat sur le coup-franc lui cherche la
mire il cherche et cherche sa lutte
arnould et voilà bon on n'a pas de
chance ça touche le poteau et épi c'est
même pas poteau rentrant c'est parce que
voilà longtemps c'est juste pas de bol
il a il était là juste pour juste pour
taper son son coup franc c'est pas vrai
c'est pas de chance
par contre est sur une finale sur un sur
un match comme moi je peux les vivres en
match de vitesse en effet vous pouvez
perdre le match ou une finale de 100 m
vous pouvez perdre le match dans la
chambre d'appel
et parce que vous vous supportez pas la
pression et c'est un temps qui est très
très court pour pouvoir interagir lassus
sur un match de super match de 90
minutes je pense pas que l'enjeu du
match une fois que les partis ni fois
une fois que malte les parties tout ça
ça cela disparaît quand même la pression
disparaît cela nous est d'accord avec
yann jorrion seront mesurés comme ça une
fois qu'on est qu'on est dedans c'est
voilà ça ne fait que
on n'a pas autre chose à penser que les
actions qu'on a menée voilà pour aller
jusqu'à une victoire ou au moins des
bons résultats car c'est avec vous une
période on va dire de disette dans le
club des templiers d'elancourt
depuis l'année dernière c'était un peu
compliqué après la victoire est une
habitude comme la défaite peut être une
habitude aussi et c'est vrai que il ya
des choses en match qu'on ne veut pas
reproduire à l'entraînement et qu'on
peut apprendre que avec l'expérience de
la compétition donc pouvoir surmonter
les situations difficiles en match et
est ce genre est ce genre de de dureté
mentale qu'on peut acquérir bas durant
la compétition
c'est vrai que ça sera jamais reproduit
à l'entraînement et on peut pas faire ça
en fait donc c'est vrai que c'est dans
ce sens pas là la victoire est une
habitude et ça se travaille genre là la
pression la pression elle intervient
surtout avant la rencontre un sport
collectif
la pression c'est sûr la préparation une
fois on dit souvent qu'une fois que le
coup de sifflet il est par du match est
donné c'est fini il ya plus de pression
parce qu'on est dans le jeu et après on
essaie on essaie qu'on me dit frédéric
on essaie de refaire ce qu'on travaille
de 2,2 à longue haleine à l'entraînement
on essaie de le mettre en place le
mettre en place son jeu n'importe quel
sport collectif c'est la même manière
mais la pression est liée plus parce
qu'on est pris on est dans une bulle et
on est pris par par le jeu et non plus
l'enjeu l'enjeu il intervient avant le
coup de sifflet du départ mais dans le
match s'est terminé après c'est c'est
c'est le jeu qui se fait avant le début
du match
une fois que vous êtes dedans p
l'un des partis ya plus aucune envie
parce que vous êtes foutus sur autre
chose voilà on connaît vos habitudes en
tout cas votre compétition il ya
dujarrier après le football le coup de
projecteur sur une discipline qui fait
parler beaucoup en ce moment c'est le
hisse portes du sport électronique le
samedi à 27 janvier l'hôtel de ville de
versailles s'est transformé en une salle
d'arcade géante au programme une
compétition du célèbre je veux médiéval
fantastique earthstone une discipline
pratiquée par plus de 70 millions de
joueurs à travers le monde présentation
de ce sport par un spécialiste
on a neuf héros différent le but c'est
de faire un deck regard paquet de 34 ont
réuni nos trente meilleurs carpes ont
choisi le héros qu'on veut et on
confronte d'autres héros au héros
adverses et on va avoir un système de
points de vie j'apprends nuit c'est
notre vie et le but ça va être de mettre
les points de vie adverse à 0 genlis a
du coup vous avez tout compris
ouais sur ce jeu bassam pékin je suis
prêt vous connaissez l'histoire autour
de cette table pour moi les échecs c'est
du sport
ça aussi c'est associer sport mais là
j'ai quand même du mal je ne connais pas
donc je peux pas me pas fait je peux pas
dire si c'est du sport ou pas puisque
yann viennent de le dire à les échecs le
bridge sas est considéré comme un des
sports donc pourquoi pas ça parce qu'il
ya quand même un travail lire
intellectuels et manuels puisqu'il
faudra les pousser hyper solide pas mais
en fait les pouces hyper solide futur
champion des dix portes genlis hélène
vous de votre côté vous connaissez ce
oui c'est ça ce qui m'interpelle un peu
c'est vraiment la définition du sport
mais on a déjà eu ce débat là je suis
toujours un peu mitigé quand on appelle
un sport où il ya enfin les disciplines
où on n'a pas de quel effort voilà on
n'a pas de d'action vraiment physique
voilà on est là on est 100 % voilà les
doigts d'accord très bien mais on est la
concentration très bien mais j'ai un peu
de mal à appeler ça sport alors esport
oui parce que voilà mais n'est-ce pas
fait des grandes rcc des jeux vidéo et
des jeux vidéo c'est pas faux c'est bien
de vouloir récupérer le tout tout
narratif du sport autour d'une
discipline mais il n'y a pas
d'entraînement physique particulier n'y
a pas de contrainte nutritionnel peut
être faire la compétition sur des chips
et du coca ça va pas empêcher de
performer le jour j alors justement
amateurs ou professionnels tous ont joué
cette compétition intensément fredrik
andersson comme de véritables sportifs
certains joueurs se sont entraînés
pendant plusieurs semaines pour réaliser
des performances sur ce rendez vous on
écoute l'un des meilleurs joueurs de
cette journée il y a une intensité qui
le mental surtout mais qui serait
bientôt sur le physique
et derrière il faut aussi savoir
entretenir son corps enrichi c'est pas
le tout de jouer tout le temps sur le
bénéfice à maurice faire du sport à côté
justement pour entretenir sa forme
mentale et physique
fredrik andersson eu une réaction il ya
douze ans non je parle pas de réaction
particulière c'est comme c'est ça ça
assez mûri comme les échecs ont leur
mairie c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose de mental et qui peut être capable
de rester concentré de deux longueurs
mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
effort physique s'est passé pas vraiment
du sport
j'aurais plutôt mis justement dans l'iss
porte
toutes les disciplines par exemple de
danse de reproduction de
de mouvement avec un écran comme on voit
par exemple ça ou comme on voit en asie
il ya pas mal de d'arcade de voile à
2,40
oui aussi mais du coup il ya nice il ya
une notion vraiment de comment dire de
d'activité physique je peux y arriver
aujourd'hui
mais voilà j'aurai peut-être plus mais
ça ou alors remis mais le golf quelque
chose de physique ça va plus on aurait
peut-être pu déjà eu ce débat sur la sur
le bridge de mémoire c'est simplement
considéré plutôt ce type d'activité
comme les disciplines de là à dire que
ces sportifs geiger ingère grand que je
ne passerais pas parce que je me pose la
question de savoir quel est l'effort
physique et quelle est la nécessité de
préparation en dehors de d'un
entraînement donc quand même ça appelez
ça de l'entraînement et l'effort
intellectuel qui pourrait assigner c'est
un sport tas de remplit pourtant comme
ça n'empêche pas à ce que ça soit
totalement spectaculaire puisque en plus
revanche de ski ce qui les distingue
c'est que c'est que les jeux vidéo il ya
jeux vidéo ea sports
sarah sonde énormément de pratiquants
dans le monde
dire que là pour le coup on peut jouer
chacun chez 170 millions de joueurs
m'ont énormément tous les âges qui
jouent chez eux donc là évidemment quand
il ya quand ya une compétition avec ceux
qui sont présentés comme étant décelés
champions de la discipline
évidemment ça fait ça remplit déjà en
plus de monde ça peut faire du spectacle
de là à dire que c'est un sport j'ai un
pote je ne franchirai pas après moi je
veux bien faire un marathon pokémon goût
oui mais là on rejoint avec tap s'est
d'abord joint l idée de l'activité
sportive
bien sûr la question sur ceux des bds
qu'il faut plus de compétition de miss
porte dans les yvelines
oui ou non une grosse cette année parce
qu'il en faut plus pour que ça se
développe genre alors si avec ça
enfin petit duel entre vous genre est
fréquent personnes qui étaient très
critiques pourtant sur l'iss porte
relève rien que c'est une discipline à
part entière et qui a besoin de se
développer comme comme toutes les
pratiques que ce soit sportive ou autre
donc je pense que plus aura de
compétition plus plus plus le sport en
fin de contrat mais villa qui l'activité
activité va se développer et je pense
que ça peut être qu'intéressant pour
tous les passionnés de cette discipline
nous c'est ce qu'on recherche au niveau
associatif et je pense que c'est
l'objectif de tous les associations
qu'elles soient sportives ou non j'en
vois là bas je suis mitigé par pourquoi
parce que effectivement et je veux jouer
frédéric dans ce qu'il a dit et c'est
vrai que c'est une activité et qui fait
venir des
des spectateurs puisque c'était c'était
comme le fait s'était rempli donc
pourquoi pas mais après je rejoins aussi
pierre en disant moi le côté sportif
j'arrive pas à quoi je fais j'arrive pas
à assimiler ça un sport j'arrive pas
j'ai joué moi j'ai joué aussi carrément
deux petits neveux là c'est bon c'est
bien j'ai joué énorme et j'ai joué mais
je vous dirai pas à quoi parce que sinon
après cinq ans vous dire donc il ya du
houston il ya également des compétitions
de jeux de football comme fifa pes il ya
des jeux de combat également comme call
of duty
au total c'est un sport qui rassemble
plusieurs milliers de joueurs dans les
yvelines
est-ce qu'il ya matière à développer
finalement des tournois ce sera deux
tonnes de pes de fifa de call of duty ln
oui de toute façon si on a des personnes
intéressées et que ça si ça rassemble
autant de monde évidemment que il ya
toujours cette possibilité
ces deux choses à développer la presse
que c'est une nécessité je pense qu'un
seul championnat c'est suffisant surtout
pas d'un oubli que ce pour ces
événements tiens voilà une activité
c'était plus décalé mais c'est
événementiel et c'est fédérateur dans la
question sur cette thématique vous
pensez que c'est une communauté de
joueurs
geek on peut le dire ou que ça peut
ressembler à un public encore plus large
yann non non ça sera bien chez moi j'ai
jouer à pokémon go et en effet je
m'aperçois que il faut connaître et
laurier très grand fan oui effectivement
je me suis alors moi j'étais pas du tout
gamer avant et j'ai appris j'apprécie ce
jeu et j'y joue il joue avec avec grand
plaisir je rencontre des gens et c'est
ce que j'aime dans d'enjeu mais mais
c'est vrai que du coup me dis que ça va
marcher mais c'est bien et ça marche pas
plus pour autant mais par contre
on aura par contre ce que je pense je
pense que voilà ces joueurs là ces gens
qui passent du temps derrière leur écran
ont aussi besoin de rencontrer des deux
se rencontrent et de temps en temps
et c'est vrai que mine de rien ces
rencontres là ben le permettent et donc
du coup il faut en organiser un organise
aussi parce que bah c'est bien sympa de
jouer dans son canapé mais aussi très
sympa de pouvoir échanger et de
rencontrer les gens de temps en temps
jarrier qui organisera peut-être des
compétitions de pokémon heroes dans les
yvelines dans les prochaines semaines
après cette large page
résultat nous allons passer à notre coup
de projecteur interne l'autre dans notre
coup de projecteur du cyclisme sur piste
la sélection française pour les
championnats du monde tape elles dorment
aux pays bas est tombé la fsl décidé de
retenir des têtes d'affiché comme
françois pervis quant à lafarge laurie
berthod ou michael d'almeida et des
jeunes pousses comme sébastien vigier 20
ans et mathilde de gros 18 ans on écoute
la réaction de ligne montrent un
françois pervis pour lui la france fait
partie des favoris avec cette sélection
je pense que dans le meilleur des cas on
peut gagner toutes les épreuves
c'est potentiellement sur le papier
c'est faisable après il ya des
circonstances de course qui font que il
ya peut-être il faut avoir aussi un mail
à un peu la chance de son côté sur
certaines épreuves
françois pervis parle de talent et de
chance
yann variés il a raison et bondues toute
façon première chose il ne peut pas se
permettre de dire qu'il va à les
dépasser sur un championnat du monde
pour faire deuxième ou troisième
c'est pas du tout son état d'esprit et
c'est vraiment un garçon qui a qu'un
vrai fight in spirit
et qui va servir de locomotive justement
pour pour les jeunes sur les épreuves de
vitesse par équipes comme il dit on a
vraiment une très très grosse équipe
pour la vitesse par équipes parce que
le tournoi maintenant se fait sur trois
manches donc très compliqué à gérer pour
le troisième homme
et là on a la chance d'avoir un michael
d'almeida et 1 quand anna phare qui font
partie des deux meilleures parties des
allées des trois quatre meilleurs
mondiaux sur le dernier tour et là du
coup on peut les servir et non c'est pas
ça qui jettera sur une deuxième place en
deuxième place il peut faire les 3 l et
les trois sprints c'est pas un problème
sur sur la journée par contre le dernier
qui se fait 750 est à chaque fois c'est
vrai que c'est un peu plus pénalisant
donc du coup avoir une bonne équipe en
qualifications un gars qui le troisième
qui se repose sur le deuxième tour et
qui aurait intègre l'équipe pour la
finale
les quatre sont de 2,2 dans ce cas les
400 coups champion du monde
c'est vrai que ça peut être une très
bonne une très bonne chose et surtout
pas du coup quelle que soit la
configuration du deuxième soit michael
ou quentin ils sont aussi fort aussi
fort l'un que l'autre donc
donc c'est très très bien un mélange en
tout cas de jeunesse et d'expérience qui
plaît également beaucoup au revenant
michael d'almeida qui n'avait pas
participé à une compétition d'envergure
internationale depuis les jo de 2016
on l'écouté l'équipe de france a
toujours eu du potentiel maintenance et
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait pour pouvoir
l'exploiter au mieux l'utiliser puis
aller chercher à aller chercher des
titres maintenant moi je de mon oeil
entre guillemets d'un peu plus anciens
parce que je fais déjà partie des plus
anciens même s'il ya plus plusieurs mois
bien sûr qu'il ya de la relève
il ya des coureurs il ya des coureurs de
talent avec de l'ambition et voilà moi
je ne doute pas que dès à présent et
dans les années à venir ça va percer
comme l'équipe de france l'a toujours
fait en fin de compte frais à 15 heures
sonnent c'est plaisant de le voir
revenir en équipe de france michaël
d'almeida il avait été exclu écarté
après les jo de 2016 à rio est ce que
c'est plaisant de le revoir revenir à ce
niveau là oui c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir des joueurs d'expérience dans
son équipe comme l'expliqué yann
meilleur l'équipe plus on a deux
possibilités niveau stratégique au
niveau des rotations et pour durer sur
l'ensemble de la compétition
donc c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait
plaisir de le voir reviens moi il ya 30
ans c'est pas trop mieux non les dans la
force de l'âge comme on l'a déjà vu en
plus aux vélos les haies
et les carrières sont un peu plus longue
que dans d'autres sports comme la
gymnastique etc ou c'est relativement
court sur le vélo on peut rester
performant même même à l'âge de yann
donc bien de jarrier est-ce que c'est
plaisant de revoir à 6 voilà michael
d'almeida était le plus jeune de ce qui
avait été exclu après roger françois
pervis et kevin sireau et michaël
michael était le plus jeune donc oui
heureusement qu'il revient et que un dtn
ne se doit pas de ne puisse pas prendre
la décision de l'arrêt d'une carrière
d'un sportif sur un sport individuel
comme comme le cyclisme c'est une bonne
chose pour pour lui je sais aussi que
michael a
à la capacité de données est d'apporter
aux jeunes je n'ai vu sur sur les
championnats régionaux être capable de
deux d'aller voir les jeunes et de leur
l'art expliqué les erreurs qu'ils
avaient pu commettre sur sur certaines
manches
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il allait
retrouver tous motivés en tout cas
l'idée de dallas fois d'apporter son
expérience a également remporté des
titres et voilà et encore il avait gagné
un titre de champion du monde en
position pour la championne seconde de
sa vallée et donc c'est quand même un
garçon qui est capable et qui est
capable d'être d'être champion du monde
et kkr et des très très performant
donc pendant plusieurs années il a été
le meilleur sur le 3e tour en vitesse
par équipes
pareil du coup c'est vrai qu'on va aussi
avoir la possibilité d'avoir des dégâts
qui vont être compétitif sur différentes
épreuves je me souviens des championnats
du monde 2015 où il avait fait toutes
les épreuves et il était complètement
cramé sur sur la fin du sur la fin de la
semaine
la voilà on va pouvoir tourner un peu
plus et avoir des gars qui seront au
niveau pour pouvoir aller chercher les
titres et les médailles donc
donc c'est très bien pour pour nous je
ne sais pas où dans quelle discipline va
courir ryan et la loci qui est un tout
jeune champion du monde junior et qui
normalement est qualifié il a 19 ans
miss inde où il va faire la division des
visuels donc bon lui va juste être là
pour prendre de la prendre de
l'expérience mais mais c'est très très
bien je pense que les les sélectionneurs
cette année on fait quelque chose de
d'intelligent cours une fois alors il y
a une autre surprise cette fois ci chez
les filles mathilde de gros trois fois
championne du monde juniors l'année
dernière qui s'est blessé à l'épaule au
mois de novembre
ce ne sera évidemment pas à 100% comme
elle nous l'a expliqué pour l'écouter
même si voilà j'ai un problème des pôles
je vais tout faire pour
en tout cas donné mon 100 pour cent à
moi je suis une compétitrice donc voilà
je vais essayer d'aller le plus loin
possible
après je vais faire avec mes moyens mais
le plus important là pour moi sur ce
championnat ça va être de retrouver du
plaisir parce que ce sera ma première
course depuis ma chute
donc voilà l'objectif c'est de reprendre
du plaisir
et j'espère vraiment être assez forte
pour aller le plus loin possible dans la
compétition
hélène il fallait la prendre dans
l'équipe type de même à 60 70 % oui oui
c'est un super espoir elle a quand même
démontré qu'elle était capable de trois
fois championne du monde juniors c'est
une sacrée performance et puis elle est
jeune donc son épaule voilà elle alla %
comme elle le disait mais je pense
qu'elle peut donner genre en donnant le
meilleur elle peut tout à fait assuré
des bonnes performances à l'équipe
entière agence à plat ce genre même si
elles viennent pas à le gagner en
expérience quoi qu'il arrive
voilà tout à fait vain gagner de
l'expérience c'est parce que forcément
avec une blessure quelqu'un soit est bon
même si c'est l'épaule mais bon l'épaule
ça compte quand même au vélo donc
forcément elle n'était pas à 100 pour ça
ça ça va être compliqué pour elle de
remporter quelque chose mais elle
gagnera en expérience au niveau de la
compétition c'est je pense que c'est je
pense qu'elle en est consciente elle est
assez avant la tête sur les épaules
malgré son jeune âge donc oui elle peut
remporter un titre ing reim non non trop
compliqué bay n'est pas à 100% et sur un
championnat du monde même si c'est pas
une année olympique même si craquant
même été trois fois j'aurai junior
juniors il ya une marge entre les
juniors et puis une christina vos
gueules ce qu'elle va rencontrer qui est
multiple championne du monde qui qui qui
va faire toute sa saison sur cette
épreuve qui va arriver au au top qui de
mémoire a remporté les deux ou trois
coupes du monde auxquelles elle a
participé en vitesse individuelle
maintenant c'est elle et christina
google domine le cyclisme féminin en
sprint depuis un ou deux ans donc pour
moi ya pas il n'y a pas photo matt il ne
pourra pas battre
christina cette année je dis bien cette
année parce que je pense que l'année
prochaine
la tendance risque de rapidement se
s'inverser mathilde a vraiment des
qualités qui sont qui sont phénoménales
et elle passera elle passera devant
toutes ces toutes ses adversaires du
moment dans très peu de temps
mais voilà c'est très très bien qu'elle
ait allait faire ce championnat du monde
elle va pouvoir voir ce que c'est voir
que c'est différent d'une coupe du monde
que
la tension la durée du tournoi n'est pas
la même que voilà toutes ces choses là
vont le niveau va aussi être supérieur
elle à pouvoir voir quel est le chemin
qui lui reste à parcourir pour être pour
être au top l'année prochaine et puis et
puis ivan et je pense que déjà elle est
de toute façon déjà très foutu sur sur
tokyo 2020 et tout ce qui se passe et
peut se passer avant n'est que pour elle
de la prise expérience avec anderson
l'épaule ça s'appelle à gênés va
nécessairement faut bien tenir le guidon
et plus ont négligé sur son vélo je
pense que plus on peut produire de un
effort important donc c'est vrai que
c'est parce que de l'handicapé tout ce
qui peut la décrire de la performance
toute façon est 1 est un handicap
après peut-être aussi ça dépend son plan
d'entraînement il faut savoir que sur
des sports olympiques comme ça en a sont
là pas forcément l'objet l'objectif
d'être champion du monde cette année là
peut-être qu'elle a plus une vision à
long terme et elle avait 18 ans et
performer à à tokyo peut-être que c'est
ça sa vraie sa vraie échéance et c'est
là-dessus qu'elle va concentrer tous ses
efforts peut-être qu'elle va utiliser
justement cet événement même s'il n'est
pas à 100% pour prendre de l'expérience
qui lui sera plus qu'utile le jour le
jour j à tokyo en tout cas les
championnats du monde aux pays-bas c'est
du 28 février au 4 mars
donc apple dorment sur le vélodrome
d'apeldoorn d'appel d'offres je vais
arriver à dire c'est la fin de cette
page cyclisme on passe maintenant à
notre focus du jour
dans notre focus du golfe à moins de
huit mois de la ryder cup 2018 au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
joueur fait énormément parler de lui et
alimente les débats du côté américain je
veux bien sûr parler de tiger woods le
tigre est de retour sur le circuit à 42
ans il a terminé à la 23e place au
farmers insurance open
paul armitage le directeur du golf
national commence commente le retour du
golfeur le plus populaire de la planète
il revient bien il revient je dirais
même en toute beauté
il a rajeuni pour moi je dirais qu'il a
5 ans 5 à 7 ans de moins
il est souriant ce qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir ces derniers temps on
voit bien que il prend plaisir
il est concentré il est juste dans ses
propos aussi sur ses propres actions
mais on sent une motivation alors je
sais pas si sa motivation et personnel
pour sa carrière en tant que
professionnel aussi sa motivation et
pour la ryder cup mais peu importe il
est de retour
pierre chevalier vous voyez son retour
d'un bon oeil je vois d'un excellent
tome il faut il faut se souvenir de ce
que tiger woods a rapporté au golf et je
dirais même au sport en général parce
que ça a été un des premiers athlètes
complets qui a qui a porté un sport
vraiment au niveau international avec
avec le des performances sportives
magnifique il est à quatorze majeurs
tout ce qui tourne aussi autour de son
image et sa communication dernièrement
on a beaucoup plus parlé de sa vie
privée et qui l'a tenu éloigné des
fairway des parcours de manière
de manière drastique la le fait qu'il
revienne ça fait déjà deux trois ans qui
prépare son retour il vient de changer
son swing il est maintenant un petit peu
de retour il a un swing qui est plus en
place qui sollicite un petit peu moins
son dos il ya eu pas mal de problèmes de
dos je sais pas pour quelle est qu'elle
est ce qu'elle sera mais en tout cas
c'est son son retour à son retour son
retour l'année de la ryder cup en france
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut que
souhaiter et qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
vice-capitaine qui soit joueur ou
l'équipe de ryder cup c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour le golf mondial
- pour l'équipe européenne peut-être
parce que ça sera c'est un catalyseur et
c'est un cetain c'est un moteur de
l'équipe américaine qu'il joue qu'il
soit vice-capitaine donc vraiment non
c'est une c'est une excellente nouvelle
déjà devoir passer un cut au tournoi de
la semaine dernière de le voir finir 23e
ça sort on avait moins l'habitude de ne
pas le voir dans les premières places
mais c'est déjà sa meilleure place
depuis deux ans et demi je crois donc
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
genre qu'est-ce que vous avez un
commentaire sur le retour de tiger woods
au plus haut niveau
c'est par peer déjà ces spécialistes
discipline c'est compliqué mais tiger en
tant qu'amateur mais à tiger woods c'est
l'image quand ce qui ne connaît pas
tiger woods ne serait-ce pour le golf
c'est une chose mais on n'avait rien à
part les havrais c'est à dire ses
dérivés par rapport à sa vie personnelle
mais mais c'est tout bon c'est tout bon
moi je suis un amateur de golf
je joue un petit peu à mon niveau et est
un gars comme tiger woods pour l'image
du golfe
c'est ce qui peut nous arriver de mieux
en france l'année où on organisera la
ryder cup c'est ce qu'a de mieux c'est
ce qu'à dieu après pierre nous a dit
qu'il a échangés so swing bon des
problèmes de dos on sait tous pourquoi c
mais bon a pas non plus revenir là
dessus
maintenant il faut également il revient
compétition je pense pas que c'est trop
le dos et plus haut niveau de l 4l au
niveau du bassin parce que les mêmes
problèmes de bassin mais il l'a réglé et
là maintenant il revient il revient et
pour le bonheur de tous alors de là à
l'imaginer à saint quentin en yvelines
en octobre prochain il n'y a qu'un pas
mais sa venue n'est pas indispensable
pour la réussite de l'événement sur
l'europôle armitage
on écoute c'est pas nécessaire
nécessairement qu'il est obligé d'être
là un jeu maintenant que je vois la
puissance de cet événement une ryder cup
avec tiger woods c'est la cerise une
ride hoc peut sans tiger woods c'est un
événement magique
la question sur ce thème tiger woods
doit-il participer à cette ryder cup
en tant que joueur ou en tant que vice
capitaine oui vous êtes aussi unanimes
là-dessus greg henderson comme ci comme
ça t'as déjà du autour de cette table je
veux dire
tiger woods c'est une image qui dépasse
de loin celle du sel celle du golfe
uniquement et c'est une vraie c'est vrai
égérie pour l'ensemble du sport pour
tout ce qu'il a représenté c'est vrai
que j'ai eu un peu de mal ces dernières
années mais ça fait plaisir de voir
revenir le simple fait qu'ils se
déplacent quelque part ça attire
forcément les les médias et le
projecteur sur sur l'événement forcément
le sa venue va aider à médiatiser encore
plus un bel événement qu'ils soient ou
pas là c'est toujours mieux de la voie
d'accords yann complètement moi je pense
mais enfin juste à titre de comparaison
les prochaines finale d'un 100 mètres
seront beaucoup plus fade sans usain
bolt donc une ryder cup sans tiger route
je pense que l'intérêt est générée ne
sera pas là ne sera pas le même
alors bien sûr qu'il y en a eu d'autres
avant sans tiger woods mais s'il peut
revenir s'il est compétitif et si les
américains s'en prive
eh bien ça va priver l'événement d'un
très très bonne d'un très très bons
éléments virtuels
le golf français jouent en 2018 sa
visibilité et sa crédibilité
la ryder cup en france c'est l'opération
lancée l'opération média numéro un
oublier que c'est le troisième événement
médiatique au monde derrière les jamais
regardé la coupe du monde de foot
donc c'est vraiment un coup de
projecteur monumentale sur le sur le
golf français sur le golf national par
exemple est le jouet jouer cet événement
là après ce qu'il ya eu comme comme
événement notamment les deux capitaines
qui tapent des bals du premier étage de
la tour eiffel c'est un match non joué
cet événement là avec tiger woods qui
est le porte-drapeau depuis mondial
depuis 10 ans 20 ans c'est quand même
comme dit paul à la cerise sur le gâteau
et si on peut le si on peut le
le voir le vivre ça sera toujours mieux
pour le développement du sport du sport
du golf en france parce que justement on
a notre à notre porte drapeau et
l'athlète numéro un qui a fait ce que
qu'est le golf actuellement à paris à 50
un hommage national
la résonance médiatique sera pas la même
avec vous sans taylor wood yahia il y
aura quand même je voulais juste que
voilà avec tiger woods c'est un plus
c'est tout il n'ya pas c'est le le le
comment s'appelle vous demandez à
n'importe qui de vous citer un joueur de
golf
la premier nom qu'on va vous sortir
c'est tiger woods il ya eu d'autres il
sait les deux seuls joueurs que je
connais deux seuls voilà donc plus seul
sur le tueur se faisait une comparaison
avec lui c'est sûr le sur l'athlétisme
en gros tu prends tu prends le tennis
c'est c'est wimbledon sans federer c'est
en l'an garros en à dalle c'est tous les
sports tous les sports ils vont de leurs
comparaisons et c'est et avoir
tigerwoods comme ne serait-ce que
présent cdg c'est déjà l'instrument
faire conduire en tant que joueur ou en
tant que vice capitaine différent gadret
pour coacher à 8 mois de l'événement et
c'est difficile de difficile d'en être
sûr parce qu'il vient juste de ressortir
il commence à avoir des résultats il
doit demeurer sur drive apparemment il a
réalisé une moyenne de 277 m sur son
dernier tournoi le 23e drive du tournoi
souvent des fermes et des féroé mais à
l'extérieur de fairway 30 % seulement de
faire ou et almeida eu un gros problème
de rigoler de régularité et performe sur
jeu court ça va mais sans violence un
peu plus compliqué les magic charlotte
sur le jeu court il est magique c'est
sûr après il faut qu'il récupère savent
suivi sa puissance avec son nouveau
swing
alors joueur joueur ou pas il ya peu de
temps pour pouvoir se qualifier
et dieu sait que l'équipe américaine va
être sacrément costaud à saint quentin
de toute façon je pense qu'il serait il
sera il sera donc dans le scope avec
avec une place de vice capitaine du psg
et c'est pas forcément un jour de ryder
cup un tiger woods voilà il y en a
partout et participer à cette ryder cup
depuis début de sa carrière il a un
bilan de 33 matchs et qui a un bilan de
13 victoires 17 défaites et trois nuls
en individuel c'est mieux il a réalisé
sept matches pour quatre victoires une
défaite et deux nuls et finissait pas
forcément un jour de ryder cup non plus
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément le
meilleur équipier qui choisit la ryder
cup c'est ça se joue en équipe 12 contre
là en l'occurrence sur plusieurs tours
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas forcément le
meilleur équipier qui soit en tout état
de cause le voir présent dans une équipe
il a un impact psychologique sur
l'équipe américaine est plus en plus
encore sur l'équipe européenne qui va
être des qui peut être déterminant voire
voir tiger en phase avec ce qu'il
représente et l'athlète que c'est le
monstre ce que c'est pour le golf pour
l'équipe américaine comme toute l'équipe
européenne c'est quelque chose qui peut
déterminer cet accord mais c'est quand
même impressionnant c'est une figure
vraiment emblématique et on peut pas
l'équipe européenne pourra pas être
tranquille d'esprit en ayant eu
les urgences conneries non mais en layon
face c'est pas 14 grands chelems
remportés 106 victoires en pro c'est une
image
ces nuages c'est le robot siffredi du
beau jeu ne permet pas envie ça va
passer un bon thème suivant maintenant à
notre rubrique débats rubrique débats
football américain dans notre page
débats le super bowl 2018 s'est déroulée
ce dimanche 4 février dans la nuit les
eagles de philadelphie ont remporté
cette 52e édition 41 33 face aux
patriots de la nouvelle angleterre
la rencontre a été suivie par plus de
103 millions d'américains en france plus
de 400 mille spectateurs ont suivi ce
match dans la nuit la question sur ce
thème le scrabble le super bowl peut-il
avoir un impact sur les clubs en france
oui ou non on fait un petit duel entre
vous pierre et et vous un jean les gens
vont commencer
merci pour moi non non je dis non
pourquoi parce que déjà un premier roman
il n'ya pas comment basket par exemple
aux états unis il n'y a pas de joueurs
français présents sur l'événement donc
ça c'est un pour moi c'est un gros point
et puis
et puis non et puis c'est tout surtout
le l'engouement ouais enfin un rugbyman
oui justement parce qu'ils sont ils sont
très protégés dans leur carcasse les de
foot us
mais je dirais que c'est surtout sur de
l'exposition médiatique que ça
représente
c'est un événement qui est extrêmement
suivi même si il passe si on regarde ma
mére l'ennemi et 400 euros et je prends
quatre cent mille en france je suis
simplement sur le sur la vie de l'aspect
notoriété sur l'aspect je dis pas de
suivre l'exemple américain se rendront
je pense qu'on en est loin en france
fred le précisera plus tôt plus
spécifiquement mais je pense que ça peut
ça peut créer quelques occasions
quelques envies comme cancon quand
auront des étudiants aux bacheliers
qu'on regarde roland garros et qu'on a
en juin et pendant envie de jouer au
tennis mais là je pense que c'est à peu
près la même chose et que le et que
super bowl avec ce spectacle et 7 c'est
énorme
c'était énorme engouement très
ponctuelle sur une date peut créer
quelques envies quelques vocations en
france il ya ne vous avait proposé de
changer l'heure des matches compliqués
doute bien que c'est pas pour les
français que les américains changeront
le changement d'horaire
non mais je trouve le problème c'est ça
c'est que cette bêta nage horaires si on
veut voir la finale en direct il faut se
réveiller en plein milieu de la nuit
donc si on n'est pas passionné par déjà
par le par le foot américain
on va pas le faire moi j'avoue que
j'adore regarder du foot us en plus le
problème
deuxième problème c'est que c'est
diffusé sur canal ces années passées
foot en gelée a pris après mais ça que
c'est quand même pas évident de d'avoir
l'information de
de savoir que c'est que ces retransmis
on sait que certains sont en pleine nuit
on sait pas sur quelle chaîne sert
transmis tout le temps j'ai donc du coup
du coup voilà il ya quand même un manque
et puis la problématique de voilà de se
réveiller un dimanche soir pour aller
bosser lundi matin
pour aller bosser là du matin c'est
quand même compliqué et donc ce manque
de visibilité fait que celui cette
bibitte en direct fait que ça ça
difficile peut difficilement créer de
l'intérêt pour pour les jeunes français
et puis et puis quand même aussi ya un
point c'est que ce au niveau des grandes
compétitions ça se déroule sur dire une
semaine quinze jours trois semaines qui
et quand c'est la coupe du monde de
football de rugby
et là c'est vraiment c'est un événement
c'est voilà une amie une nuit c'est un
match une nuit je pense pas que sur une
nuit sur un match c'est à dire tient
demain matin je voulais je veux jouer
tous les week-ends c'est comme non mais
ça ponctuent mais bon est-ce que les
gens est ce que les gens en france
non mais ce que déjà en france ce que
les gens en france on regarde on dit
souvent on dit souvent que ça amène du
lissage ici en france lorsque c'est une
compétition qui regardaient en france et
qui dure sur un temps le handball le
football le rugby tout tout tout ces
compétitions
parce que voilà on est amené et puis on
est arrivé on arrive on a ri puis
souvent parce qu'aussi il ya une équipe
française qui est impliqué dans le
championnat et la c1 engouement qui se
crée on se dit ah ben tiens voilà
et là on enregistre dans les damnés
fédérations délégataires une
augmentation de licence mais là sur une
compétition sur une finale
une nuit qui seront transmis la nuit en
france danton oui il faudra français
dans l'équipe non mélangés aux français
l'équipe c'était le début ce que disait
mais c'est surtout parce que c'était
juste ponctuelles et que c'est une
finale et qui française c'est à nous
voilà non mais c'est pas un joueur mais
même un joueur déjà au moins un joueur
on en parlerait peut-être un peu plus
comme le basket la nba il perdra karpatz
voilà tony parker ou ou noir mais
on n'en parlerait un petit peu plus mais
là on ne parle jamais du football eric
est jamais on ne parle que de la finale
du super bowl
donc je ne pense pas que juste en
parlant de la finale du superbowl
frédéric qui est le spécialiste de la
discipline
je sais que je vais être avec moi ça
semble gelé l'émission donc je sais que
ce sera avec moi mais forcément sur une
finale on ne peut pas c'est pas possible
fait d'accord personne en bas après ce
qu'il peut avoir un effet oui encore un
effet moi je sais que c'est comme ça que
je suis venu au football américain j'ai
regardé le super bowl un soir et ça m'a
je suis tombé dans la marmite
après de là à voir un effet notable
c'est ça on reste un sport confidentiel
on est bien on y vient un peu par hasard
donc c'est vrai quoi là c'est vrai que
dès qu'on peut intéresser des gens ça
peut toujours être un plus à prendre une
petite fédération ça va pas
révolutionner sport on va pas avoir un
impie que de besoin à plus de 220
seconde laisse souvent 2987 licencie fin
2016 ouais et c'est vrai que on a du mal
encore à se développer donc c'est sûr
que si on si le super bowl eux générer
des vocations tous les ans que beaucoup
plus loin donc c'est vrai que c'est ça
reste un sport exotiques con qu'on
maîtrise peu parce que les règles sont
compliquées parce que c'est pas un style
de jeu qu'on a l'habitude de voir c'est
très haché c'est une action une pause
une action une pause beaucoup de pauses
télévision serait que les matches sont
très longs et passer 10 yards pour trois
essais pour passer dire la base oui
après quand on rentre un peu plus dans
le détail des nuances stratégique
ça peut être compliqué mais bon après ça
reste ça reste une passion avant tout je
pense onu on y vient surtout par
curiosité puis on y reste parce qu'on
est devenu passionné on a chopé le virus
et et on laisse plus tomber quoi mais
mais non c'est pas le super bowl qui va
révolutionner le football américain en
france et bien en france la finale
en france la finale c'est juste une
information on vous donne comme
information le résultat de la finale du
superbowl c'est pas un suivi du
championnat american value est peut-être
plus de l'extra-sportif finalement que
voilà le tour est en lui-même on a plus
[Musique]
vous êtes âgés n'ont rien de jarrier sur
20 reconnaît bieber sont fans mais non
mais c'est vrai qu'on a plus vu là la
présentation est tout ce qu'il ya autour
le super bowl que la performance
sportive par elle même donc c'est pour
ça et la vie privée du quarterback des
liens avec avec le mannequin c'est vrai
qu'on passe pas mal de temps sur le sur
les à-côtés les à côté d'un événement
plutôt que sur le purement sportif voilà
qu'est ce qu'il ya quand même des
joueurs qui lui quand même qu'ils
viennent vous voir
après le match pour avoir des
renseignements c'est rarement pour
envisager de s'inscrire peut-être pas
pour cette saison et pour la saison
prochaine à ses plus c'est plus comme ça
que ça se passe on voit le super bowl en
février et puis on rend bien compte que
que le bal à la saison est déjà
commencée comme tous les sports comme
tous les sports qu'on peut voir comme le
rugby le football et inscriptions
s'assure en septembre mais généralement
oui les gens viennent plus en septembre
où j'ai vu super beau j'aimerais bien
essayer
après il reste pas tout ça vraiment
c'est vraiment un sport particulier avec
tout un savoir faire qui à acquérir et
une compréhension du jeu qui est assez à
s'élaborer donc oui c'est on y vient par
passion par hasard et on reste dedans
parce qu'on pense que ça nous a plu on
n'a pas aimé l'ambiance et et on a mais
on aime le contact est parfois aussi
tout tout tout là on va dire toute la
mythologie qui peut y avoir à côté par
exemple john mccain a le casque avec le
logo dessus ah je préfère le logo de
cette équipe là et puis après des
rivalités de danse et c'est très peu
fort autour est vraiment très
intéressant
coupé de la fin sur cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi à 8 février pour une
nouvelle émission on va terminer par une
citation de l'un des golfeurs les plus
connus de l'histoire tout simplement
l'un des golfeurs qui a le plus marqué
l'histoire c'est jacques nicklausse le
défi du golfe c'est d'accepter d'être un
parfait
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]